it's my great pleasure to introduce Phil
Rosh visiting us today from P an eval
few words about filled he got his
Bachelor got tuning from bachelor
degrees from university of washington in
1976 one in ms Rick's audience of one in
chemistry and I went to Florida State to
get his master's in meteorology and also
a PhD from Florida State but he got he
spent at that time of a tank car when he
got his his PhD and stayed on in car
afterwards I the postdoc in a scientist
for about 20 years I think they're right
back and then moved to P&L in 2008 it's
been there since and field works on a
range of different topics in that
mystery science general circulation I
was for chemistry and most recently have
said a lot of work on engineering and
it's also in charge batte chapter to
engineer in Chapter to see report so
we'll hear about some of us work on she
engineering thanks Trudy it's a pleasure
to be here and I'm sorry for the delay
in getting started this morning it's I
it's fun to be here and I've enjoyed
chatting with some of you this morning
as well I'm going to talk to you about
geoengineering which has over the last
five years or so occupied more of my
time than I ever planned it to I started
out working on it at the invitation of
paul crutzen who wanted somebody to work
with him on modeling a particular
geoengineering problem and then
gradually got more and more entrained in
it over the years it's the work that
I've done has mostly been through
cooperation with some postdocs and young
scientists and I'd like to tell you
about some of that work today when Trudy
and I talked as well she mentioned to me
that there was going to be a series of
for talks on geo engineering and the
seminar
and that but Alan robock had who I
gather was also one of the people asked
to give a presentation chose to talk
about nuclear winter so what I've
decided to do is to provide you with an
introduction to geoengineering as well
as then tell you some of the thing about
my own personal research and what I've
done in it and I like to start off with
this cartoon I almost always sorry guys
everything that could go wrong will go
wrong let's just turn it off
I like to start off with this cartoon
because it sort of tells you what the
what the difficulty is I hope all of you
had a chance to read it the issue is
that we're gradually recognizing that
fossil fuels are an issue in climate
change and it's very difficult to make
the transition to other sources of
energy and another example of that that
I like to show is this picture from
paper by rock and the proceedings in the
National Academy in which he shows in
the black lines here a time series of
the fossil fuel emissions as estimated
from measurements alongside a set of
scenarios that are have been used
historically for anticipating the
changes in fossil fuel use and and are
produced to project out fossil fuel
change 'as to as far as 2100 now these
particular scenarios have now been
superseded by a different set but in the
early days it doesn't make a whole lot
of difference that through 2010 or so
you'll notice that in the recent past
post-2000 that the emissions have
exceeded the highest levels that were
anticipated by this set of scenarios
these are actually just the scenario
averages and there are fans of scenarios
associated with each of these lines that
do exceed the current emissions but
these are the midpoints are the best
estimates of those scenarios and if you
look at what's happened in the more
recent past you can see that the problem
is just getting worse in spite of our
attempts to to deal with with fossil
fuel emissions so this is sort of
motivated the possibility of considering
something called geoengineering which I
define here as being an intentional
change to the climate system which is
designed to counter some of the effects
of increasing greenhouse gas
and I've introduced a question here to
recognizing first that we are changing
the climate system and whether it's
worth while thinking about introducing
change is deliberately rather than
carelessly and this is sort of
provocative I don't really I'm quite
uncomfortable with answering this with
the answer yes I don't want to but it's
there there are some reasons why it
might be interesting as I will leave you
with a message in my closing that there
might be some reasons to consider
deliberately and very temporarily
introducing changes as a mechanism for
understanding the physics of the
atmosphere or the climate system better
even if one made the decision never to
deploy any of the strategies which I'll
talk to you about today so the other
thing is to acknowledge the people who
I've been working with and they're
listed either down below they're a
little less directly involved with my
current research and the ones up above
who I'm going to cite a lot of their the
work that they've been doing with me
over the last couple of years so to
begin this I want to remind you about
the energy flows in the atmosphere and
what's regulating the temperature of the
planet it's essentially the planet is
initially governed by the amount of
sunlight entering the top of the
atmosphere some of it is reflected off
of clouds molecules and aerosols in the
atmosphere and returns directly to space
a lot of it and it some is absorbed as
well as a the sunlight passes through
the atmosphere and some of it is again
reflected at the surface and about half
that entering the top of the atmosphere
is absorbed by the surface the
temperature of the planet warms and
begins remitting in the infrared and
some of the energy is returned to or
begins its Traverse back to space in the
form of infrared radiance or radiation
and other parts of it appear in latent
and sensible heat fluxes
as the energy is emitted from the
surface it's again absorbed this time in
the infrared and I'm quite a bit of it
as emitted or is absorbed and re-emitted
by the atmosphere some of it goes up and
the rest of it comes back down and a
good part of it is taken up by
greenhouse gases and clouds also act as
a greenhouse medium if you will so the
the mechanisms that are being so I'm
going to talk to you in quite a bit of
detail about one class of geoengineering
techniques which is called soul it was
with tongue-in-cheek originally labeled
as solar radiation management or SRM but
it also is called sunlight reflection
methods these are methods which are
methods that are designed to increase
the reflectivity of the planet slightly
by either increasing the brightness of
clouds or introducing additional
aerosols into the atmosphere or changing
the surface reflectivity of the
atmosphere some of them are also
designed to decrease the greenhouse
effect either by removing greenhouse
gases or by making high-level clouds
cirrus clouds less opaque to infrared
energy and two days worked in that area
very recently so this is a that's very
brief overview of the basic concept of
geoengineering and I'm going to spend
another five or so slides on kind of
putting a little bit more detail into
this and talk to you about results from
the early research that I did primarily
and using these one of these sunlight
reflection methods which utilizes
stratospheric aerosols as an analog for
volcanic eruptions and another way of
changing boundary layer clouds and I'll
spend quite a bit of time than telling
you about some very general results of a
model intercomparison activity that's
been taking place over the last couple
of you
cheers and you'll see that there are
some names that I've repeated on or
indicated in an earlier slide there also
so I'll get into more detail about geo
matter so there are these two different
classes of methods which I've already
described to you the carbon dioxide
removal and solar radiation management
here are a variety of the techniques
that are being postulated that could
work and if you begin to look at these
in some detail than what you find is
that they can be broken down it is sort
of two broad classes of results that the
carbon dioxide removal mechanism zar
because they're getting at the heart of
the problem the increase in greenhouse
gases by removing the carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and sequestering it
in some non gaseous form if if you could
do it safely that would be getting at
the heart of the problem it might be a
possible long-term solution all the
estimates that have been put together
right now or that it would be very slow
if you were to use natural methods it
could take hundreds of years to draw
down the co2 that we've already injected
in the atmosphere in the last 50 years
and it would be quite expensive and then
there are class of techniques these SRM
techniques which I'm characterizing is
probably not a long-term solution but
they're very cheap to do even even if
you take the costs that are have been
estimated for some of these strategies
and multiply it by orders of magnitude
it would still be cheap compared to
either making a transition from a fossil
fuel based economy or to employing some
of the carbon dioxide removal techniques
so there was a nice report that was
written by the Royal Society about three
years ago now in 2009 and I've taken a
cartoon from that which show which
attempted to do an assessment of the
costs the effectiveness whether it's a
variant of a natural phenomena how hard
it would be to get it read
and they've scored each of the various
strategies which I've mentioned to you
before in terms of these things and two
that have been deemed relatively
promising are listed here in the upper
right corner of this figure
stratospheric aerosols which I'll talk
to you more about in a minute and the
boundary layer cloud seeding but in fact
if one was ever to consider doing this
it may actually pay to consider a
combination of approaches by far the
most satisfactory solution is to just
cut the fossil fuel emissions from the
start but also you could do this in
concert with sucking out co2 and
changing the reflectivity of the planet
for certain reasons and we can talk
about that later also by the way I
really like to be interrupted when I
give talks so if people have questions
feel free to inject them in it so the
first thing I wanted to do is just to
remind you this was actually the
eruption of Pinatubo a couple of days
this is a pre eruption of Pinatubo the
day after that it really went off and
what one sees in the observations is
that following that eruption which took
place in 91 the planet cooled by about
half a degree as indicated by the solid
black line here the models which have
introduced the aerosols are able to
reproduce this kind of cooling as well
and there were other consequences to the
planet also wonder is able to find
changes easily measurable changes in the
amount of water vapor for example the
column integrated water vapor and models
also reproduce those signatures there
are in addition to cooling the planet
there are some negative or well some
consequences that are of some concern
the top panel here is showing you these
are both from trend birth and dies paper
and is showing you a time series of the
amount of sunlight and long wave energy
reaching this
surface and the sum of those two and the
sign convention is such as through when
you see this positive change by 5 to 10
watts per meter squared this is a
reduction in the sunlight reaching the
surface and at the same time if you
monitor the amount of fresh water
discharge from rivers across the planet
and then estimate from it the land
precipitation you can the conclusion is
that there is a significant reduction in
the amount of precipitation reaching the
surface at the same time and I'm going
to come back to this in more and more
detail because it's one of that well
really that was have been the focus of
some of the recent research that I've
been doing with my postdocs so for those
of you who don't know how stratospheric
aerosols work I've taken this cartoon
there are many sulfur bearing species
that are emitted by volcanoes either the
the slow law or the small volcanoes that
percolate along all the time as well as
emissions from various ecosystems that
introduce sulfur bearing gases in a
reduced form they are relatively inert
and many of them become well mixed and
when they reach high altitudes they
those gases can be oxidized well some of
them are inert some of them are very
reactive but a significant amount of the
sulfur species reach the stratosphere
the lower stratosphere where they're
oxidized to make sulfuric acid gas and
the temperatures in this part of the
planet from the equator to pole here are
sufficiently cold that the sulfuric acid
gas condenses and make small particles
and well you think of volcanoes is
putting a lot of ash into the atmosphere
it's not the ash that's really the thing
which affects the cooling of the planet
it's the particles that form after words
from the sulfur bearing species
these sulfur sulfuric acid particles are
their mixtures of sulfur sulfuric acid
nitrogen species and water they mix
along this region layer of the
atmosphere called the tropopause just
above it and gradually they get mixed
mixed in to the lower part of the
atmosphere where clouds scavenge them
very efficiently and they can also the
particles can get quite big and they
sediment out as well if the particles
are mixed into higher altitudes the
temperatures actually get warmer again
and those particles evaporate and there
re they undergo chemical reactions which
put them back to sulfur dioxide and then
the cycle can return over and over again
also so I'm going to talk to you now
about a set of simulations and the
conclusions that we've come from them
using general circulation models and
some very high resolution models called
large eddy simulation models as well and
for at least for the general circulation
model studies what I'm going to tend to
do is to show you differences between a
series of simulations oftentimes I'll
call out a control simulation where we
assume that co2 concentrations exist in
pre and pre industrial con
concentrations and there is no
geoengineering done and then we will
difference them with simulations in
which we increase co2 and we oftentimes
increase it to double or quadruple the
amount that is present in the times
around 1850 at 285 parts per million or
even present day it doesn't really
matter much and look at the differences
between these two simulations and then
to also explore what might happen if we
introduce various geoengineering
solutions or combine increasing co2
concentrations with geoengineering and
we look at differences in various
important fields and the processes which
are controlling them and try to infer
from this what would happen
in a if these techniques were to be
employed in the real world so just to
give you kind of a feel for how things
operate what I'm showing you here are a
set of simulations that were done with
the general circulation model that i use
the ccsm and these are cross sexes top
panel is a cross-section of the
atmosphere of the planet from the South
Pole to the North Pole and altitude on
the ordinate here in kilometres and what
I'm showing you here is the where the
aerosols are located from introducing a
source of sulfur bearing species in this
case sulfur dioxide which is introduced
at about 25 kilometers in the tropics
that sulfur dioxide oxidizes and makes
these aerosol particles and they spread
out and occupy this region of the planet
if you integrate the mass of this layer
of aerosol species in the model and plot
the the vertical integral the mass
weighted integral of this of these
species you get a picture that looks
like this with the red values showing
where the aerosol would tend to collect
and the yellow values telling you where
the aerosols would be relatively low
I've chosen to show you the June July
August distribution because I want to
make the point that when the sun is
shining in the northern hemisphere that
the radiative a force refor Singh or the
reflectivity the reduction in the amount
of sunlight reaching the surface
maximizes over the North Pole where the
sunshine is and where this layer of
aerosol is also and that there's also a
signature of the aerosol and the tropics
where we have been emitting the
precursor gases that oxidation takes
place over a few days to a month in in
time and so you see it you also see a
reduction in the sunlight reaching the
surface in the tropical region
so what are the consequences this in the
top left panel I'm showing you the
surface temperature change the
difference between an experiment and the
control in this case for a doubling of
co2 and the temperature change is
indicated here on the right the left
panel is for the doubling of co2 so you
see the warmest temperatures in the
polar regions and really the warmest
temperatures are at the Winter Pole and
you also and then on the right panel I'm
showing you the consequences of
introducing these sulfur parts of uric
acid particles into the lower
stratosphere this is for a simulation in
which I haven't attempted to entirely
balanced the the greenhouse gas warming
but you can nevertheless see that the
temperature changes are much lower than
they would be in a world that in which
there was no geoengineering the middle
panels here are showing you the impact
on precipitation the blue values are
indicating where precipitation is
reduced and the red values where it's
increased and what you see as a
signature which is common to many
general circulation models of an
increase in precipitation in the
tropical regions for high co2
concentrations and a decrease in the
flanks of the of the tropics here as
well and then where where the colors are
white in both and all of these panels
it's an indication of areas where there
is not much change compared to the
pre-industrial simulations the changes
are small and where you see these hatch
marks is where the differences are
statistically significant according to
estimates that I can describe to you in
more detail if you're interested but I'm
also showing you that in the lower
panels the a similar calculation of
simulation that was done with a
different general circulation model and
the take home message here that you'll
see is that
that the signatures are quite different
I think you should only pay attention to
the right panel I I'm not can't remember
what the exact strategy that we use for
the left panel is but the point is that
where it's low or their increases and
decreases in this model is not the same
as where there's increases and decreases
in this model and so the regional
consequences of this geoengineering are
quite uncertain at this moment but what
the that's one message and the other
message is just that the change is the
GCMs are hinting that the changes in
precipitation would be reduced compared
to a simulation in which only greenhouse
gases were allowed to increase there
will be other consequences to the to the
planet as well it ends up that ocean
ozone depletion takes place on these
stratospheric aerosols and there are
sites for the reactive photochemistry
that's involved with ozone depletion
particularly in the presence of the
reactive chlorine species that are
produced by the release of
chlorofluorocarbons and what I'm showing
you here are changes in the
concentration of ozone that are as
calculated by a model that we put
together to try and assess what the
consequences of the would be to the
photochemistry of the atmosphere and
what you see here is in blue regions
there is ozone depletion and in the
orange colored regions there's actually
an increase in ozone and if you
calculate again the vertical integral of
this latitude height cross section then
you would conclude that in general the
introduction of the stratospheric
aerosols would decrease ozone in the
over the over Antarctica and and would
actually prolong the presence of the
ozone hole by 30 to 50 years this ozone
hole is supposed to go
a as CFCs gradually are depleted from
the atmosphere at the around the end of
the century so it would take a process
that's going going to go for at least
another hundred years if our models are
correct out another 30 to 50 years there
would actually be some increase in ozone
in the tropical regions so another
strategy is to brighten clouds I
mentioned this to you as well and I've
chosen to start by demonstrating the
impact that humans can have on clouds by
showing you these features in the cloud
fields this is a satellite retrieval in
this case I think this is off the coast
of California and these streaks here are
so-called ship tracks which are caused
by the emission of pollution into the
boundary layer and those small particles
act as sites where cloud drops form and
if you increase the number of sites
cloud condensation nuclei and the
boundary layer then what you find is
that those particles are competing for
the water available water vapor and so
you will get each droplet that forms
would be a little bit smaller than it
would be if the if the pollution was not
introduced into the atmosphere there
would be more drops than they would be
smaller than the areas where these ship
tracks are not seen and I've also want
to show you that there these signatures
occur in a variety of different cloud
types there are here a variety of
different kinds of clouds ranging from
what are called closed a cellular
convection to open cellular convection
and you see these kind of brightening
effects in both areas so a simple theory
that was developed by Shawn to me in the
70s suggests that if you introduce more
aerosols they make more drops smaller
drops and by simple physics you can show
this would produce a more reflective
cloud
and estimates have been made of how much
it would take to change or two to change
the clouds in a manner which might
counteract clouds are a very effective
mechanism for cooling the planet and
Tony Slingo on a paper in 1990 suggested
that by relatively modest changes in a
number of drops or an changes in the
cloud drop size or increases in the
oceanic cloud cover you could counteract
a co2 doubling and these were these
numbers that I'm providing you with here
are the numbers for any one of these
effects to operate if all of these
effects are operating then the changes
would be much more modest than this in
each of these features so this
stimulated an idea by John Latham in the
90s which was to maybe consider
deliberately introducing particles into
the boundary layer his idea was that you
take some seawater convert it to very
small drops introduce these sea water
drops near the ocean surface where
they'll evaporate and make salt
particles or salt and organic aerosol
particles that can act that would act as
very efficient cloud condensation nuclei
and to produce the aerosol particles in
a manner which would let them be very
efficient cloud condensation nuclei that
would out-compete the natural aerosols
in making cloud drops so Latham
suggested that this was an idea which
could be used as well for brightening
the planet and a variety of people have
made studies about where what cloud
systems would be most effective to
brighten and this diagram which I'm not
going to talk to you about very very
much detail indicates some of those
regions where it's yellow and red these
would be effective places tip to
brighten the planet and these are areas
where these marine stratocumulus and
trade cumulus systems reside so what
happens if you introduce those if you
assume for the moment that we could
perfect introduce and control the
behavior of the clouds perfectly what
with those clouds in those regions that
I just showed you what would be the
impact on on the precipitation
distribution and the top panel here I'm
showing you the distribution from a
general circulation model that result
that I made and in the lower panel the
change from the geoengineering so what
it indicates is that there are places on
the planet where precipitation would be
reduced where it's very intense here in
the Intertropical Convergence zone and
there would be shifts of the South
Pacific convergence zone as well now
this again is another model this one is
a model run in England and I want you
only to focus on one particular location
and that's over the Amazon in this model
in this simulation that I did the model
is showing that precipitation would
actually decrease over the Amazon if you
introduced these aerosol particles in
the mat office model it shows that you
would that I say decrease i meant
increase and in the mat office model
their souls would decrease precipitation
so again the signatures are very
uncertain there is also effects on sea
ice and in spite of the fact that we're
introducing these changes to the clouds
in the tropics you can show that just
because there's generally a reduction in
the amount of energy reaching the
surface of the planet you can have an
impact on the sea ice distributions
these blue areas are showing you the
okay so this is the North southern and
northern hemisphere where the where the
changes are in late summer for each of
the hemispheres in march in September
the for a doubling of co2 the blue areas
are indicating where the sea ice the
model predicts the sea ice would be lost
if you put just the right amount of
geoengineering in then you reduce the
effect significantly if you if you put
in a whole lot of geoengineering then
you will
potentially overdo the effect also so I
told you that this these effects operate
on the clouds but what it's important to
recognize is that clouds are very poorly
handled in general circulation models
today and so we've also attempted to do
a much more careful job of simulating
those clouds and to do it in a large
eddy simulation mode over a very small
region of the planet for a very short
period of time and I'm going to focus on
this region off the coast of California
where these clouds are very prevalent
and show you a set of simulations done
with approximately a million times
smaller grid spacing than the mesh that
you see here for which is typical of the
kind of a mesh that is used for solving
for doing climate simulations over the
globe so what we're going to do is to
focus on simulations these are satellite
simulations again which show over very
narrow regions this red box is
indicating the size of one of the
general circulation model boxes and
inside that red box you can see areas
that are have what are called open
cellular convection as indicated in the
top right panel as well as closed
cellular convection so what we've done
then now is to mimic introducing a ship
or a set of ships in this case this
laser pointer is run out of juice and
what the ships do is they sail from the
left-hand part of this model domain
which is only about 100 kilometers long
and 100 kilometers high these three
ships are sailing from left to right and
when they there are doubly periodic
dimensions so when they go in about one
end they return and come back in the
other side and i'm showing you snap
shots at six hours 12 hours and 18 hours
into this simulation and the right
panels here are showing you the particle
district
the distribution of sea water particles
that we're introducing into the model
domain and the left panel is showing you
the changes in the clouds so the clouds
start out to be mixtures of a close
cellular convection and some open
cellular convection by this time the
ships have propagated most of the way
across the domain and you can see the
impact of the wakes and six hours later
the clouds have evolved and in this
region the albedo is relatively low and
they're low the clouds are the scene
albedo is also quite low but you can
still see remnants of the of the plume
of aerosols that were introduced into
the model as well as some areas where
the closed cellular convection is also
maintained and but you'll also see that
there are these wakes of dark regions
here which are to the each side of the
the cloud systems or the cloud plumes
and this is a feature which is shown
later in time as well we've looked at
various eating strategies with these
detailed high resolution models and I'm
showing you here what would happen if we
were introduced one ship that's
injecting the same mass of seawater into
the atmosphere but doing it just as one
ship and going over and over through the
model domain and here is the signatures
that you see if you if we use this
different seating strategy again what
you see our bright regions surrounded by
darker regions so one can compare the
the albedo of these clouds to the albedo
that would be present in the simulations
without having introduced the extra
clouds and the conclusion is the ships
do brighten the planet but they don't
brighten it anywhere near as effectively
as are hypothesized in GCMs right now
the the distribution of sprayers the
magnitude of the flux the kind of cloud
systems
the environment they all make a huge
difference in terms of how much the
clouds will brighten and the GCMs are
not doing a very good job of mimicking
these effects right now so I'm going to
now switch gears and kind of that was my
introduction and just remind you that
the models and the observations have
suggested that the global precipitation
distributions would drop if the planet
became brighter and I'll spend some time
talking to you about why and then the
models are frequently disagreeing on
regional responses and this gmf
intercomparison activity this model
intercomparison activity was designed to
try to reduce some of the variations in
the simulations that were done by the
investigators who have looked at
geoengineering up to now and what we've
chosen to do is to try and set the
problem up so that everybody can do
exactly the same simulations okay yeah
if you have a like a small island retro
a little ocean where waves are crashing
into beach introducing a big spray of
soft focus mm-hmm would it do the same
so can you hope services through the in
the current atmosphere this process
going on localized regions of intense of
a great in causing you can't see it you
can't see it in from they haven't been
able to them because clouds have so much
variability they haven't been able to
demonstrate it in the in from sea water
or if sea spray what there's a related
study which has been done which is there
is a small volcano near one of the
Hawaiian Islands is going off right now
and one can very clearly find the wake
of the of the block anak plume which
it's a low-level volcano that just goes
steadily downstream of the volcano so
you can see at perturbing tradeking
brightness but for seawater I'm not
aware of any studies which is shown so
this just tells you how the the gmf
intercomparison activity goes so what
one does is with the black line I'm
indicating that a simulation is done
with pre-industrial forcing up to a
particular point in time and then a
perturbation is introduced and in one
perturbation you quadruple co2 indicated
by the red line producing a positive
forcing and the planet isn't expected to
warm and in another simulation you
introduce a forcing a negative forcing
which is just sufficient to counteract
what would be present in the four times
C a to experiment and the simplest
possible thing to do is to turn down the
amplitude of the sun and this is quite
far fetched obviously but there is a a
strategy which has been which I haven't
spent any time mentioning but was on a
previous slides which is to introduce
reflectors in space which could scatter
some of the sunlight that would normally
you would put it in your a Lagrange
point and it would be just sufficient to
scatter just enough sunlight back to
space to counteract a particular amount
of warming now it ends up that that
those reflectors and spaces the
estimates are it would be enormously
expensive and we don't have the
technology to do it today so it's not
looked at very often but but it would be
a very close analogue to this particular
experiment and then finally do
experiments in which you turn both the
positive and the negative forcing on
simultaneously and I'm going to now kind
of switched to showing you some results
from this intercomparison activity and
framing it in terms of fast and slow
climate responses and for fast
experiments or fast responses the
typical way that people characterize
what they call the fast response to the
climate system is how our field changing
before surface temperature really has
had
chance to respond or to respond very
strongly and the slow responses is what
happens to the fields after the surface
temperature has been allowed to change
so I'm just going to review the
mechanism that's been developing from a
variety of people in in some later
slides here so but the first thing I'll
do is to show you the results of the
quadrupling of co2 in the Northern
Hemisphere winter and summer and for the
four times co2 the the you know the
experiment was designed to really hit
the planet with a hammer and there's a
very large warming of seven or eight
degrees with temperatures as high as 16
degree changes in the northern
hemisphere poles to the quadrupling of
co2 and then the results for the the
combined forcing so cooling the planet
by reducing the amount of sunlight
reaching the surface and warming the
planet by introducing the four times co2
and what you can see are that there are
still some residual effects you see a
high latitude response primarily in the
winter hemisphere polar region and also
some other regions where there are some
disser nabol differences and the
stippling in these plots is been
introduced to indicate where 75% of the
dozen models that will participate in
e.g in the inner model intercomparison
agree as to the sign of the difference
so wherever you see it stippled it's an
indication that there's a coherent
signature across all the models
so now I'm going to just try and go over
what happens with these changes in the
forcing agents and I'm going to first go
over what would happen if you cranked up
the sunlight and if you do then
increasing the amount of sunlight would
increase the surface flux you would get
a warming a but a very small warming but
enough to change the stability to
increase surface turbulence and to
through the turbulence to be moving more
both heat and water out of the boundary
layer and anticipate that you would get
an increase in precipitation and with a
slow response after the temperature
begins after this positive forcing
begins to be felt by the system you
would get a warming in the of the these
I should have said that these are
supposed to be just schematic diagrams
of temperature versus altitude for a
particular column or for the global
average of the of the planet the
temperature changes would kick in and
then following that you would also see
water vapor and lapse rate feedbacks
kick in but we don't typically we try to
isolate the water vapor the feedbacks
from the other fast and slow responses
how about for co2 well the first thing
that would happen is increasing the
greenhouse gases would immediately warm
the column aloft because of the
absorption and ambition of the outgoing
long-wave radiation and the fact that
the the greenhouse gases are relatively
long lived and the heating is relatively
uniform over the column and what it does
is to stabilize the column and reduce
the amount of turbulence near the
surface leaving the surface a little bit
warmer and a little moister than it
would otherwise be suppressing
precipitation so in a fixed SST
experiment if you just double co2 the
precipitation actually goes down but of
course if you allow the surface
temperature
to respond then the surface eventually
temperature eventually increases and at
that point in the game the evaporation
rates can also increase and you will you
get more moisture in the column and
combinations of lapse rate feedbacks
water vapor feedbacks and the just
absorption and emission by the increased
water vapor as well as the co2 which is
what we think is really happening in the
planet so now what happens if co2 is
high in sunlight is reduced so the red
line is supposed to indicate the profile
from the high co2 and if you were to
decrease the sunlight then you will
again increase the stabilization or the
stability of the profile and again
reduce evaporation compared to the
present day and if you put just enough
in to bring the surface temperature back
to the present day or pre-industrial
temperatures then you're going to be
left with a column which is more stable
than it would otherwise be even if the
surface temperature is the same as today
so it's precisely that last situation
which we think is the explanation for
the reduction in precipitation that is
seen in the trend boren following a
volcanic eruption as well as the
signatures that we see in the models
also i think i'm going to skip this
figure so here i'm showing you the
changes in from the GM experiment for a
four times co2 precipitation change on
the left and in this case this is the
signatures are quite similar to the
things i showed you before with an
increase in a Intertropical Convergence
zone now this is the multi model mean
from the gym from the 12 models that
were in the gmf intercomparison and a
reduction in precipitation along the
flanks of the ITCZ as well as
significant increases elsewhere on the
planet including increases over places
where there are monsoons and increases
to high latitudes as well and in the
storm tracks after putting in the the
geoengineering you get a very different
signature in this case consistent with
the volcanic signatures you see a
reduction in the precipitation over a
lot a lot of places on the planet but
again I'll point out to you that the
white regions are regions where but the
the precipitation changes are relatively
modest there are some significant
regions where the models agree that
there would be changes either reductions
in precipitation or increases in
precipitation if you look at the
components of this thing then the top
panel is showing you that it's the same
as a figure I showed you on the previous
panel here's the signatures and the
evaporative flux and you see that really
the most there are vast areas of the
oceans where there are differences but
there are also very significant changes
over the over some of the land masses
and a combination of precipitation minus
evaporation is shown here if you look as
well at the primary productivity
indicating the the effect that it could
have on ecosystems you can see that
primary productivity for the four times
co 2 minus control increases let's just
ignore the middle panel and the lowest
panel here is the geo engineered world
so this would be the productivity of a
world with today's or pre-industrial
temperatures but with an enhanced co2
concentration make it just is suggesting
that plants would have an easier time of
it
so now I'm going to just describe to you
briefly some of the changes in the in
precipitation intensity over the top
panel I'm showing you so that on the
abscissa here are the precipitation
intensity for the models showing you
whisker diagrams which are not showing
up very well and apologize but for
different precip intensity intensities
and this is the yeah the difference the
change in precipitation compared to the
control for the ensemble of models for
four times co2 for the ensemble of these
12 models and for the geoengineering
experiment on the right and what you see
so these are only monthly mean
precipitation this is not the you know
daily or instantaneous precipitation
differences in the frequency of
occurrence but you see that in a
four-time co2 world that the high
precipitation amounts will tend to
increase when measured globally or when
measured only over the monsoon regions
both over land and ocean land in red and
blue oceans as well as in the
Intertropical Convergence zone and that
if you then begin to try and tease out
what's going on in the geo engineered
planet you see the precipitation is
reducing the frequency of occurrence of
high precipitation indices is actually
reducing for overall regions of the
planet so this would indicate that the
yeah the most intense precipitation
would be tend to be the ones which are
most strongly influenced
the same occurs in mid-latitudes but
it's even more dramatic for the well the
for the models the precipitation
intensity and mid latitudes goes up a
lot for the four times co too much less
for the jew engineered planet the top
panels are for the winter precipitation
in the lower panels are for the summer
in the Northern Hemisphere we've also
looked at the signatures for these
various monsoon regions and the the the
signatures are essentially the same
Trudy I'm not paying attention to the
time but how am i doing at this point ok
good I can do that pretty quickly so
here's the mill take-home messages the
first one is this diagram is intended to
show you a measure of the difference
compared to present day climate compared
to co2 and one for various fields which
are indicated here when the line when
these symbols are located near the this
top line it indicates that these this is
the change in the climate as a function
of the amount of geoengineering and when
the line when the symbols are located
near the this location of zero here it's
indicating that this particular amount
of geoengineering was enough to return
in this case northern hemisphere sea ice
to something looks like present-day
amounts but you'll see that that amount
of geoengineering might return northern
hemisphere sea ice but it wouldn't
return surface temperature precisely to
present day it wouldn't return southern
hemisphere sea ice or precipitation when
however if you measure according to I
think I'll just skip this one this the
messages are quite similar now here's
may be the last science result i'll show
you that Alan robock did a nice study a
while ago in which he he he made a
simulation of a try
can see an evolution of the planet to a
one percent per year increase in co2 and
then at a certain point he began
geoengineering and the different colored
lines here show different amounts of
geoengineering the red line being
designed to take you back to
pre-industrial surface temperatures and
the blue line indicating very little
geoengineering and they fixed it for the
at a particular a solar amount of
sunlight reduction for this period of
time for about 40 years or something and
then postulated what would happen if for
some reason we decided that a mistake
had been made and we needed to turn off
to yo engineering and you see these
temperature traces showing the
consequent recovery of the planet when
you introduce when you turn off the
geoengineering the rate of temperature
increase is very rapid and this would
enter really seriously Stu stress
ecosystems for example or adaptation by
humans as well yes we are so this red
line this thick red line shows what
happens to the temperature if no
geoengineering takes place so it
continues to go up and the blue line or
black or this sort of orange colored
line is for various amounts of
geoengineering so if just a little
geoengineering the planet cools a little
bit but it still goes up it stays cooler
than it would have been the black line
the same and the red line he's
introduced a lot of geoengineering so
you don't see the response yet I think
I'll skip this one and I'm going to
close now just there's lots of messages
this was sort of an overview as well as
a few recent results there's loss of
messages to communicate to you and lots
of subtleties I can't talk to you or I
haven't had a chance to talk to you
about but these are some of the things
that I wanted to make to leave you with
the first is there's an inexact
compensation by sunlight reduction
it's not really a complete solution you
can see that you can't balance
precipitation if you try to balance
temperature you won't balance the amount
of sea ice so the to invoke some this
kind of a geoengineering strategy is at
best a partial solution and some issues
are not addressed at all for example
ocean acidification in any of these
strategies of modifying the amount of
sunlight reaching the surface the ocean
will continue to take up co2 and it
continued to acidify because of the
inexact compensation it doesn't make any
sense to me to start unless there would
be a clear path to an energy transition
to a non fossil fuel burning solution
and and you knew how to mitigate the the
co2 effect so if you wanted to get past
four to avoid for example of tipping the
possibility of exceeding a two degree
temperature change to to reduce the
probability of reaching a tipping point
maybe it would make sense to invoke some
kind of a SRM technique but only if you
really because it gets increasingly
risky as co2 increases it would be it
would be a risky solution unless you
knew there was a way out and a
risk-benefit analysis would be necessary
because it doesn't compensate everything
equally there would be winners and
losers there is obviously a huge number
of ethical moral and practical issues
not to mention the issues of diplomacy
and negotiating treaties to do this kind
of stuff and then the last thing that I
want to just say is one of the things
which I have suggested in a number of
papers is that there might be useful
things that could be learned about the
physical system by deliberately
introducing small scale effects into a
set of clouds for example that wouldn't
really affect climate but would tell you
whether we really understand how clouds
Brighton for example or what the
consequences that brightening would be
to the surface energy balance
these are things which are just basic
physics and they're relevant to
geoengineering also and they could be
invoked even if one from the beginning
ruled out a full scale deployment that
was designed to counteract co2 increases
and I'll close here Thanks a
relationship these studies reflecting on
drought areas that need more
precipitation do the agriculture yeah
there I mean there are eight locations
and some of the figures that I show
which i didn't spend time on but if you
look for example in the monsoon regions
you see that there are with four times
co2 you get many situations where there
are reductions in the frequency of
occurrence of these intensities and
there are other circumstances where you
see an increase in the frequency of
occurrence of these very intense
precipitation situations so there will
be the implication here is that that
there may be times where droughts and
floods are being affected by four times
by by the perturbations that we're
interview the anthropogenic
perturbations that we're introducing and
gc-ms are tending to say that it's the
rich get they call it sometimes the rich
get richer phenomena but that wet areas
are going to get wetter and dry areas
are going to get drier and I think the
the signature is that the GCMs are
providing is to say those situations
will occur much less frequently if you
invoke geoengineering now I don't know
whether to believe the GCMs or not but
they're providing a consistent signal of
those things and and I've already told
you that geo that that the climate
models tend to not agree very
all in terms of their regional
characterization also they may our full
report had a lot of consistency between
models on the goal predictions but not
so much on the reject and my friends
copy they are far apart is about San
deckers they haven't really had much
confidence to the regional yep reports I
wonder if you could you I think this
bear simulation what you trying to do
here I'm trying to figure out what's the
reason why we're not making progress on
the regional predictions as to what
extent does that impact trying to say
here well I don't know the reason why
we're not making better progress on
regional on regional characters
characterizations of climate change
right now I know there are many aspects
of models with many easily identify a
little deficiencies we're working on
them but the thing is that that also I
see as a as a model developer is that
over the last five years we spent a lot
of time putting in new physics putting
in carbon nitrogen cycles for example
putting in isotopes putting in variety
of different new things aerosol cloud
interactions are treated much more
comprehensively than they were six years
ago when previous generation of the IPCC
was in but we haven't tried so what
we've been doing is making models more
complex and not necessarily trying to
hammer down the systematic errors we
have done that also but I don't think
we've been doing as much of it as it
deserves and I don't know where I don't
know how to I I can't identify an
optimal strategy for where we ought to
be putting our energy because who's to
say that the additional complexity that
we've worked on over the last five years
is not necessary to get the regional
effects right so I don't know where I
don't know I can't reprioritize the
research and say what is most important
why do we use the alias bone that it
wasn't getting close to the changes
what's up orders of magnitude right well
Sully the good that one of the messages
is that the detailed models also suggest
that it's possible to brighten clouds
the whole scene is brighter than it
would be in the absence of
geoengineering introducing the the sea
spray aerosols does cause the scene to
brighten but not as much as GCMs
brighten and the I mean this is a
signature that I think GCM modelers we
know and Trudy can tell you to is models
are over we think they're overly
sensitive to the introduction of aerosol
GCM levels are so I mean a lot of
modeling results but aside from your
last point in the summary side what what
is where are the experiments yeah well I
mean part of the problem is it's such a
controversial topic that a number of us
we there are white papers around
proposing field experiments and there
are also there is work that has been
done that too for example produce sea
spray with the right size distributions
to affect the aerosols but to do a sort
of a comprehensive field experiment a
really let's say a field experiment that
affected a domain over a few hundred
kilometers on a side with a significant
amount of era of change in the albedo
its to do a one month experiment would
be tens of millions of dollars and there
are I mean we've floated the white paper
around to program managers and it's just
too controversial to be considered at
this point in the game now last note two
years ago now Lynn Russell at UCSD
scripts went out and released a bunch of
smoke and aerosol particles in off the
off the Scripps pier well in the off the
coast of California and looked to see
whether she could find ship tracks for
example and or and she can to see
whether it could be week one could
predict the behavior of those ship
tracks and the answer is it was a very
she bought the smoke generating machines
off of ebay for a few thousand dollars
she had small NSF grant to do this she
mentioned in one paper that it was
applicable to geo engineering but it was
not a geoengineering experiment it was a
cloud seeding experiment the clouds
which are being seated here by the way
are ones which are quite different from
the cloud seeding that's being done to
promote rain for example and I could
talk to you about that if you wanted to
know but at any rate there's there's no
funding to do this kind of work